president Trump is reversing course and
saying he will have a health care deal
quote very quickly the president
predicted last night that Congress could
reach a bipartisan agreement over a
potential future plan this morning CBS
News poll shows most people don't blame
anyone for the Republicans failure to
pass their plan about half of them say
the bill failed because it just wasn't
popular Margaret Brennan is at the White
House with the president's message on
health care Margaret good morning good
morning well the president appeared
newly confident that he'll strike a deal
with Senate leaders last night at a
dinner here at the White House he told a
bipartisan group of 61 senators and
their spouses that he wants to negotiate
I know that we're all going to make a
deal on health care that's such an easy
one so I have no doubt that that's going
to happen very quickly I think it will
actually I think it's going to happen
because we've all been promising
Democrat Republican we've all been
promising that to the American people so
I think a lot of good things are going
to happen there now as a stunning change
in tone from just last Friday when mr.
Trump vowed to let Obamacare fail and
blame Democrats for the defeat of his
health care replacement plan in the
house of course it was infighting within
the Republican Party that sank that bill
but speaker Ryan said Tuesday he's not
giving up and some lawmakers want him to
keep negotiating in the meantime the
White House is testing new strategies
including moving the existing Obama care
system in a more conservative direction
and that option of working with
Democrats won't be easy Gale because
there is so much pressure from their own
base to resist collaborating with
president Trump all right Margaret thank
you